hello and welcome to this talk from the
Elle Child Study Center program
for anxiety disorders and in this talk
we'll look at the way that a child's
anxiety might impact the family system
and add some strategies for parents to
support their child in overcoming
anxiety and facing their fears it's no
surprise that parents of children who
experience a lot of anxiety become drawn
in to the child's difficulty because
after all people are mammals and young
mammals rely on their parents for both
protection and reassurance when they
experience anxiety one helpful way to
think of the way a child's anxiety might
affect the family dynamic is to think of
anxiety as blurring the boundaries
between parent and child for example
parents and children occupy different
space indicating them being two separate
individuals such as when a parent is at
work and a child is at school or when a
parent sleeps in one room and a child
sleeps in another but when a child is
overly anxious that space might go away
as when the child needs to be in the
same room as the parent all the time or
when a child wants to sleep in the
parents bed parents can ask themselves
questions such as are my actions a
reflection of my beliefs and goals as an
individual and a parent or am i engaging
in actions because of the need to
alleviate my child's anxiety for example
parents of children with
obsessive-compulsive disorder often find
themselves performing compulsive rituals
because otherwise the child feels
anxious for example repeatedly checking
locks on doors because otherwise the
child is too afraid to go to sleep
parents can ask themselves whether their
time is managed by themselves or by the
child's anxiety disorder
as when a mom needs to take multiple
phone calls over the course of the day
from an anxious child or when parents
devote endless time to answering
reassurance seeking questions even
emotions can become entangled between
parent and child when a child suffers
from an anxiety disorder so that parents
feel swept away by the child
anxiety and reflect their own fear back
to the child in one example a
seven-year-old girl was repeatedly taken
to the emergency room at night by her
parents because of difficulty breathing
stemming from anxiety although doctors
reassured the the parents that the child
was physically quite healthy they were
unable to withstand the anxiety of
seeing their daughter struggling to
breathe and of course the child's
anxiety was tremendously heightened by
the experience of being rushed to the
hospital at night parents of children
with anxiety disorders will often face
many dilemmas and ask themselves
questions such as should I give in to
this anxiety or should I demand that my
child cope better is this real anxiety
or are these just reassurance or
attention-seeking behaviors is my child
just misbehaving or even questions such
as Who am I allowed to tell about my
child's anxiety in trying to help
parents better support their children
it's helpful to address some common
misconceptions were traps
that parents fall into because of their
children's anxiety and although these
misconceptions seem to make sense or
appeal to intuition they can be
significant roadblocks to a parent's
ability to support their child in
overcoming anxiety one such idea is the
thought that anxiety is a dangerous and
damaging emotion and that it's the role
of parents to protect their children
from experiencing anxiety in fact not
only is this factually incorrect as
anxiety is a normal and healthy
phenomenon which children are well
equipped to experience it's also a very
problematic message to the child
it's as if parents are saying to the
child you're not able to cope with
anxiety and so I have to protect you a
child who comes to believe that they're
not able to cope with anxiety is almost
assured of continuing to suffer from an
anxiety disorder until the attitude
changes and so rather parents should be
striving to convey to the child
message you are able to cope with
anxiety I'm sure that you can deal with
this and I'm going to help you to
overcome this problem another parental
trap that parents will often fall into
is the idea that the child's anxiety
needs to be kept secret from anyone
outside of the immediate nuclear family
in fact many adults have suffered from
anxiety in childhood describes someone
outside of the home as being most
helpful to them in overcoming their
fears grandparents uncles aunts
neighbors and counselors can all be
tremendous sources of support to both
parent and child if they're allowed in
and allowed to speak with the child
about the anxiety and offer help and
support another misconception that can
be a real trap to parenting an anxious
child is the thought if I acknowledge
that my child is really afraid then I
can't ask them to overcome that fear
it's really easy to fall into the trap
of insisting you're not really afraid or
it's not really frightening but a child
is likely to experience this as a kind
of misunderstanding or even abandonment
because it's as if we're saying to the
child I don't believe that you feel what
you feel but the child internally knows
that they are really afraid and so
rather than being supported they're
likely to feel more alone and less
hopeful about overcoming the fear so
it's more helpful to convey to the child
the message I know that you are afraid
but I believe you can overcome this this
is the stance that we attempt to help
parents to adopt with regard to their
child's anxiety a stance of support in
other words combining the idea of
acknowledgement and empathy for the
child's inner experience of fear and
anxiety combining it with a belief and a
true confidence in the child's ability
to withstand anxiety and some gradual
expectations for increased coping
sometimes one of the most difficult
aspects of parenting a child with
anxiety disorder is identifying and
reducing all those ways in which parents
are accommodating to the child's anxiety
disorder this could be through changes
to the parents routines and timetables
it could be through providing
reassurance or it could be through doing
for the child things that they would
otherwise be expected to do for
themselves
for example a child with social anxiety
disorder might be reluctant to speak to
someone else and their parents might
have become accustomed accustomed to
speak for them or parents of a child
with obsessive-compulsive disorder might
feel that they need to engage in rituals
such as washing their hands repeatedly
before serving food because they know
that otherwise the child becomes very
agitated and will sometimes even refuse
to eat the food that's served this can
obviously be very distressing to parents
but we know from a lot of research into
childhood anxiety disorders that as long
as parents continue to accommodate the
child's anxiety disorder the likelihood
of that child overcoming the disorder is
quite dramatically reduced another
difficult aspect of parenting a child
with an anxiety disorder is the strain
that the child's anxiety can place on
the parents ability to act cooperatively
and collaboratively between themselves
any number of factors can contribute to
this difficulty for example parents
often have different expectations of the
child one parent might think that not
going to Boy Scouts or sleepovers is a
sign of disorder while another parent
might feel that that's a legitimate
choice on the part of a child and this
could lead to conflict sometimes the
different amounts of time that the two
parents spend with the child can
contribute to their different feelings
about the child's situation such as when
one parent only comes home after the
child is already in bed while another
one has spent hours reassuring the child
or having to accommodate to their
anxiety disorder sometimes differences
in
attitudes to her child rear and can
cause conflict as when one parent is
more authoritarian and believes that
strict demands should be placed on the
child while another one is more
democratic and thinks that the child
should be allowed more greater leeway
and more freedom in choosing how to
conduct their own life all of these and
many other factors can contribute to the
difficulty in working together sometimes
conflict becomes so pronounced that each
parent sees the other as actually
damaging to the process rather than as
helping the child to overcome the fear
but as we've seen support for an anxious
child actually means combining two very
different attitudes combining
acknowledgement empathy and acceptance
of the experience with gradual demands
for coping and with the confidence in
the child's ability to withstand anxiety
and so more often than not although
parents might significantly disagree
both of them are standing for an
important aspect of support for the
child which is quite necessary in
helping the child to overcome anxiety
recognizing this and coming to see the
other parent as reflecting an important
aspect of support rather than as
damaging to the process can greatly help
parents in collaborating around the
child's anxiety increasing communication
about the child's anxiety can also be an
important tool for increasing
cooperation unfortunately many parents
will only talk about their disagreement
or about the child's anxiety in the
moment when the child is experiencing
anxiety and they're under tremendous
stress but this is unlikely to lead to
productive communication setting aside a
special time to talk about the child's
anxiety and to discuss strategies for
better helping them to overcome the fear
can be an important part in increasing
cooperation
additionally we sometimes encourage
parents to trade roles just briefly
sometimes for a few hours or one day so
that the parent who has been in charge
of reassurance and empathy takes on the
responsibility for helping the child to
overcome fear and takes on the role of
greater expectations from the child
whereas the parent who has been
completely responsible for demands and
for coping now finds himself responsible
only for reassuring and comforting the
child when anxious this can help parents
to see the value in the other parents
point of view and to decrease conflict
and increase collaboration and so
childhood anxiety disorders can place
significant strain on a family system
but parents are often able to support
their child and help them in overcoming
fear and growing healthier and more able
to focus on other adaptive and important
aspects of growing up thank you
you